you've got to hand it to the Mandalorian
this possible plot hole has fans talking
the Mandalorian season 3 finale is here
and boy did the showrunners prove once
again that they know how to end a season
the return has all that any Star Wars
fan could want mandalorians doing aerial
combat with their jet packs then jarring
going bull John Wick and grogu finally
putting his Force training to work
however there's one casualty in the
episode that didn't make much sense the
darksaber has been a contentious object
throughout the Mandalorian whoever
wielded the ancient weapon had the right
to rule Mandalore so mafghanian and Boca
tan spent much of their time trying to
win it back however in the season finale
Gideon does a complete 180 destroying
the legendary weapon in his fight
against bokeh tan the darksaber is gone
well Gideon's motivations are confusing
the bigger question is how he even
crushed the darksaber with his hands not
only does he destroy it but he does so
with relative ease while somehow leaving
bocatan's hands seemingly intact it's
not enough to ruin the finale but it's a
glaring plot hole that needs more
explanation Star Wars fans aren't
exactly known for their ability to let
things go so the Mandalorian getting rid
of a powerful Star Wars weapon like the
darksaber has proven to be a
controversial move within the fandom one
Reddit user commented after the episode
aired kind of upset that the darksaber
got destroyed other users had similarly
strong opinions on the fate of the
legendary artifact with one fan calling
it quotes the second most emotional
death of a non-character in the greater
Star Wars Canon while it seems that most
fans agree that the weapon's destruction
was impactful the conversation quickly
shifted to how its demise ultimately
made sense within the Star Wars Universe
one user asked how is Gideon able to
squash the hilt like that another viewer
replied I think a suit may have had some
mechanical improvements but another fan
pointed out that the bescar's hilt
should have withstood the hydraulic
assisted fist one fan also pointed out
that mop getting and should have
completely destroyed bocatan's hand if
he had enough strength to crush the dark
saber other users took a different
approach suggesting that the death of
the darksaber was for the best one
Reddit user admitted they were happy to
see it Go saying now the Mandos will
just have to actually pick the best
leader in the future another suggested
that it plays into bocatan's character
development writing she needed to
realize she is still the ruler of
Mandalore even without the dark saber
fans certainly have opinions on how the
season 3 finale of the Mandalorian dealt
with the darksaber but there's a slight
chance that the weapon isn't gone for
good from what fans know about how
lightsabers work all variants of the
weapon are powered by a core kyber
Crystal if Gideon didn't crush the kyber
crystal that the darksaber presumably
contains within and its most vital
component is still intact some fans are
even pretty confident that the dark
saber will see a comeback in season 4 of
the Mandalorian or Beyond one fan wrote
on Reddit there's definitely a good
chance it will get remade yeah kyber
crystal inside is probably still fine
some even took the theory a step further
with one fan suggesting it will be none
other than the newly anointed didn't
Roku who reforges darksaber after all
the fresh Mandalorian Apprentice needs a
fittingly powerful weapon whatever the
ultimate fate of the dart saber is it's
ostensible destruction in the
Mandalorian season 3 finale will
certainly have Ripple effects it seems
at least for a time that the
mandalorians will have to learn to live
without the ancient weapon
foreign